obviously so much of our story is built
on the hero's journey of overcoming
obstacle and yet everything in society
today is telling us you know conflict's
not okay you know challenge is not okay
we've got to be safe we've got to be
like prevented from having challenges
whereas actually it's it's challenge
that enables the human Spirit to grow
and to
overcome I'm Dave Ruben and joining me
today is the baroness at the UK House of
Lords and the CEO of the alliance for
responsible citizenship also known as
Arc baroness felipa strad welcome to the
Ruben report thank you so much Dave
really great to join you well I'm very
happy to have you because I will be
joining you guys at the ark conference
in London in about a week and a half or
two weeks or so uh and I thought we
could just chat for a few minutes about
what the conference is all about sort of
how this originally came from the uh I
think I can say the great mind of Jordan
Peterson uh what the Genesis of all of
this was and and what the intentions are
so I I'd love to talk to you about
British politics but I think we have to
focus on that um so can you talk about
what Ark is how Jordan got to you and
and where you want to go with this thing
yeah thanks Dave so Ark is really a
movement of people who are basically
saying that we've had enough of a
declinist permac crisis poly crisis type
way of thinking we actually believe that
there is a better story A Better Way
Forward and a more hopeful narrative and
because we so believe in story because
it shapes who we are and it shapes our
direction of travel as societies that we
actually want to come together to
develop a better story for our
society but actually when I think back
to how it all
started um I had invited Jordan to come
and do a talk um at the think tank that
I led in London and um we had a
fantastic time with him the whole time
we were focused on freedom of speech and
higher education and how we restored
freedom of speech and academic freedom
back to our universities and at the end
of it he went on his way did a big tour
around e Eastern Europe and halfway
through that tour he rang me and he said
Philipa everywhere I go there are people
fantastic leaders but they're so
isolated and they're doing amazing work
what would happen if we brought them all
together to do a conference in London
and I thought great story and at the end
of it he just said to me Philipa do you
know this chat called Paul Marshall I
said yeah great friend of mine so I
pinged an email and said hey Jordan meet
Paul Paul meet Jordan you're going to
love each other next couple of days Paul
Rings me and says you know this
conference that you and Jordan are doing
I'm in and I what conference anyway it
kind of just snowboard from there and
you know when um like an idea's time has
come it just has momentum behind it and
people wanting to get on board and make
it happen that's what Ark has been like
from beginning to end I have to say just
on a personal note as you know I toured
with Jordan in 2018 and 19 about 120
shows I think 20 countries and what you
just described there of all these great
people coming up to him after the show
political leaders politician politicians
celebrities thinkers authors blah
everyone was like we've got to do
something so I'm so thrilled for this
thing I really can't wait but do you
find it strange you mentioned stories
and obviously that Jordan has been a
great EXP explainer of why stories are
important you can't just give people
policy do you find it odd that the West
which has come up with so much great you
know movie making and books and
literature and and all of the stuff that
our culture is made of we somehow didn't
tell a story to defend ourselves does
that seem you seem like a strange
dichotomy to you yeah and it's like our
story's got so fragmented so one of the
questions we're going to be asking at
ARK is what can we draw from our history
what what is the narrative the story
that can unite us as we go forward and
we're asking like what story can be
drawn from our liberal Democratic
history and what story can be drawn from
our judeo-christian history are there
stories that actually can be
foundational to who we are that can take
us forward and obviously so much of our
story is built on the hero's journey of
overcoming obstacle and yet everything
in society today is telling us you know
conflict's not okay you know challenge
is not okay we've got to be safe we've
got to be like prevented from having
challenges whereas actually it's it's
challenge that enables the human Spirit
to grow and to overcome so there are
lots of different themes like this that
we're going to be exploring at ARK as
well right and the conference is it's
four days if I'm not mistaken is it four
or full days yeah it starts on Sunday
the 29th and then is going through the
30th 31st and 1st of November so Monday
Tuesday and Wednesday in London so
excting so we're going to we're going to
link to it down below because obviously
portions of it at least are still are
open to the public and we want people to
be there and all of that um what what
other types is it fair to call it sort
of a counter to the world economic Forum
sort of a bottom up way of looking at
the world as opposed to a top down
version of looking at the world yeah so
it is um a gathering of leaders um at in
London but it's also really profoundly
built around the principle of
subsidiarity so what am I responsible
for as an individual what is my family
responsible for what is my community
responsible for and then what is my
nation responsible for so so instead of
hiding away um somewhere and coming up
with these big decisions than imposing
them on society and pushing them down
it's very much coming up from the
principle of responsibility at every
level including including the individual
and then on the on the night of the 1st
of November Jordan's throwing open the
the doors at ARC at the O2 huge place
where anyone can book a ticket um it
takes 20,000 people Arc and it's
literally open to anyone who can get a
ticket they're going very fast if they
haven't already
gone right and and what are some of the
like categories that you're going to be
talking about so I think people
understand sort of broadly what you're
talking about but this is going to be
about science it's going to be about
tech media Etc right like there's it's
going to be sort of AC cross all
disciplined yeah so the the big question
we're asking is what is the better story
but within that too it's like what is
the better story for for family and the
social fabric what is the better story
for business what is the better story
for energy and the environment so it's
asking right across the board all these
like what is the better story and all of
these different aspects of life there's
so much that we want to platform that um
I think it's going to take years two
three four to to platform it all but
there's there's um it's all going to be
framed around that lens of the better
story and and is the plan then I I
assume so but I that the plan will be
okay we're going to come up with sort of
specific stories that can lead us to
policies and then we're going to find
the people that might be in the House of
Lords or in the United States Congress
or elsewhere and we're going to try to
implement some of this stuff absolutely
and what's really exciting too is that
we've got um at least half the sh half
the shadow cabinet from Australia coming
3x Australian Prime Ministers are coming
we've got two Congressional delegations
coming from from the us we've got over
100 different MPS from different uh
parts of the world coming so we have
some people of real influence but we
also have 200 Business Leaders uh 200 um
another 200 kind of uh ideas and
influencers as well so I mean it's going
to be a very rich rich
audience do you think there's anyone in
the world that could have pulled
something like this off other other than
Jordan like when I first heard about
this I was like oh this is what Jordan
was supposed to do it just seems so
obvious to to me in a
way I mean he's a remark well you know
this he's a remarkable individual and um
I love working with him I think he he's
an extraordinary man but what's been
really great in the art conference is
the ability to gather other likeminded
Extraordinary People Too we've got over
90 speakers um who are going to be
platformed people wanting to come and be
on the stage and and contribute and I
think um you know this sort of change
Jordan would be the first person to say
it it can't be through one person it has
to be through a movement of people but
oh my word he's been the most
extraordinary
Catalyst does it also feel to you that
the timing is kind of right not just
because of what's been happening in the
world for the last couple years
obviously but really even the events of
the last 10 days or so really have the
West feeling very shaken I mean I'm
seeing the obviously the protests that
are happening in London but they're
Happening Here in in New York City and
other places here as well
yeah I I would I would really agree with
you Dave I think um one of the questions
that we're asking is where did we lose
our confidence and how did we lose our
values in the west and would these
events be happening if we had more
confidence in who we are as people more
confidence in our values and um I think
we've got you know fantastic historians
like Neil Ferguson who are going to be
joining us um we're hoping that we will
have some extraordinary spokes people
even from Israel who are able to join us
that aren't announced yet and obviously
for obvious reasons uh may not be able
to join us but I think um I think this
is a moment for us to really ask
ourselves some difficult questions and
say actually we've got to strengthen
ourselves we've got to have more courage
we've got to have um a better story to
tell I think actually we should leave it
there so that people will hear a small
bite and then of course we're going to
be recording everything and there'll be
all sorts of videos that'll get out I'm
going to try to do some interviews on
the ground even even if I got to do it
from an iPhone we'll we'll chat with
everybody there and uh I just want to
thank you for putting this together and
working with Jordan on this links to the
tickets to the uh o or link to the
tickets to the O2 event are right below
do you have any final thoughts Before I
Let You Go no just can't wait to welcome
you to London Dave as well I can't wait
thank you so much if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
screaming check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification Bell